application avec notre envoyé spécial
pauline godard
nourriture vêtements produits de
première nécessité les couches ici
l'aide affluent du monde entier
lorsqu'un réfugiés passent la frontière
il a tout ça à disposition gratuitement
donné par des ong et des bénévoles des
stands remplis dont certaines personnes
tentent de tirer profit elles se font
passer pour des réfugiés remplissent
leurs sacs et repartent du côté
ukrainien ventre les produits c'est du
vol nous ont expliqué les policiers
polonais ils passent régulièrement
devant chaque stand pour prévenir les
volontaires mais il n'ya pas qu'ici que
les disparaît c'est aussi le cas de
camions envoyés en ukraine par des ong
ils n'arrivent jamais à destination
certaines organisations ont donc mis en
place un système pour que ça n'arrive
plus notre supérieur prend une photo du
camion quand le chargement et terminer
comme ça on peut voir de quelle façon
les cartons ont été rangés quand le
camion arrive en ukraine ce qui récupère
le chargement prennent à leur tour une
photo pour voir si tout est bien rangé
de la même façon et si tous les cartons
sont là il nous montre une photo des
alentours pour que l'on voit que le
camion est arrivé au bon endroit l'autre
priorité ici c'est d'assurer la sécurité
de ces femmes et de ces enfants qui
traversent chaque jour la frontière une
population vulnérable à la merci des
trafiquants tout est fait pour les
sensibiliser on a pu constater qu'il y
avait plus de policiers qui
patrouillaient dans le camp des tracts
comme celui ci sont distribuées et
affichées sur les stands également sur
les toilettes s'il y est écrit de ne pas
donner son passeport de ne prendre que
les moyens de transport officiel de
rester ensemble et de ne pas accepter
d'offres d'emploi les trafiquants n'ont
pas l'air méchant rappelle le tract